it was not a particularly warm welcome
for the US vice president today in
Brussels but unlike the protesters
camped outside the you council building
EU leaders had long been looking forward
to Mike Pence's visit the offense let me
first of all thank you for this meeting
we all truly needed it after all there
was much to discuss during Pence's first
official visit to the European Union
capital with EU foreign policy chief
federica mogherini with Commission
President jean-claude Juncker with NATO
secretary-general installed back and
with EU council president donald tusk in
hours long meetings pence tried to
reassure the europeans about his boss's
stance toward the block today is my
privilege on behalf of President Trump
to express the strong commitment of the
United States to continued cooperation
and partnership with the European Union
whatever our differences our two
continents share the same heritage the
same values and above all the same
purpose that's a major change of tone
Donald Trump welcomed the UK's brexit
vote and has at times seem to be
lobbying for the breakup of the you
protesters in Brussels criticized that
as well as the Trump's administration's
Muslim travel ban and its treatment of
minorities no he's not an American
problem they're importing American
problems into our society and I
completely disagree with the way they
are handling it I also disagree with the
way they're setting different people up
against each other where we should be
collaborating and working together we
don't want to live in a world that's run
by people have these values right so we
want we believe in freedom of speech and
equality and equal rights for all and
that's not what the champ is
administration supports while Pence's
visit is unlikely to dispel the concerns
of many EU leaders officials in Brussels
say they are encouraged by his
statements but they will be watching
closely to see how far Donald Trump's
actions match his deputies words
you